Since its announcement, Hulu's biopic "Pam
& Tommy" has been wrapped up in controversy.
The series depicts a more idealistic time in
the mid '90s when celebrity sex tapes were not
as frequent as they have come to be. This caused a
perfect storm for Pamela Anderson, played by Lily
James and Tommy Lee played by Sebastian Stan,
when their private honeymoon video was stolen
from their home. Many have come out against even
the idea of such a series portraying this story.
The notorious singer for the grunge band Hole,
Courtney Love, defended Anderson's right to
privacy. She said in a statement "My heart goes
out to Pammy further causing her complex trauma".
Love's statement refers to how Anderson
was treated by the press at the time.
She was publicly shamed by many outlets, and
according to Entertainment Weekly, she refuses
to ever watch the show. The new Hulu series
is from "I, Tonya" director Craig Gillespie,
who was also criticized for his sympathetic
portrayal of Tonya Harding in his previous film.
In addition to these factors,
there is one former band member
that has some strong opinions about
Lee's portrayal in "Pam & Tommy."
Formed in 1981, Mötley Crüe was a hair metal
band that quickly became known for their antics.
One of their most famous anecdotes is the time
Ozzy Osbourne snorted a line of ants, which is
detailed in the band's memoir and film of the same
name, "The Dirt". What may be lesser-known is the
brief period of time when frontman Vince Neil left
the band, which is not portrayed in "Pam & Tommy."
In 1992, Neil was replaced with John Corabi,
who performed with the band for five years.
Corabi sang on the band's self-titled album
in 1994, and did not continue when Neil
returned for the comeback album in 1997. For
Sebastian Stan's transformation into Tommy Lee,
the actor reached out, and Lee officially gave
his blessing to "Pam & Tommy." Despite this,
Corabi does not agree with how Lee is portrayed
in the limited series. In a powerful statement
on his social media, Corabi defended many
players who this real-life story touched.
On his Twitter account, Corabi published a
lengthy statement in defense of the real-life
people who were involved in the story behind
"Pam & Tommy." The singer was adamant that
the character of Lee in the show is a work
of fiction, and not relevant to reality.
Corabi wrote in his statement, "I shared
5 years of my life with Tommy,[...]
And although at times it was INSANITY it's
sooooo overblown." The singer went on to explain
that these events were sensationalized
for what "they call tv entertainment."
In the show, Lee is often demonstrated
as being outrageous and oftentimes cruel.
The main catalyst for the aforementioned break-in
and subsequent theft of Anderson and Lee's
sex tape was because of Lee's treatment
of his former carpenter Rand Gauthier.
Gauthier expected to be paid for materials
and to retrieve his tools from Lee's property.
Instead, Lee met him with a shotgun and
refused to pay him. Later in the series,
Anderson is shocked to hear that Lee
refused to pay for services rendered.
Corabi's defense isn't just extended to Lee.
There is another significant
person who he goes to the mat for.
Pamela Anderson was a sad footnote at the time
of this scandal. As portrayed in "Pam & Tommy,"
Anderson had to face the brunt of abuse from
comedians like Jay Leno, while Lee was often
let off easily from the limelight. Corabi has
come to her defense in light of this trauma, too.
He wrote on Twitter: "Apparently HULU, and
all involved in this crock of s*** don't
care about how Pam may feel to have to
relive this". His concern also extended
to Anderson and Lee's two sons who they continue
to co-parent, despite the end of their marriage.
There are elements of Anderson's life
that are not in Corabi's statement and
are entirely glossed over in "Pam & Tommy"
as well. As Showbiz CheatSheet states,
the couple briefly reconciled after Lee's spent
time in prison due to spousal abuse. The Hulu
series mentions the domestic violence in Anderson
and Lee's relationship briefly in the end credits,
but did not make that a priority in the series,
nor did Corabi mention it in his Twitter post.
Anderson has been through many trials
because of this time in her life,
and continues to stick by her decision
not to be involved with the show.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.